now let's bring in our first guest
tonight author
of laptop from hell fox news contributor
miranda devine miranda i was just
thinking about all this thinking about
your brilliant book about hunter biden
and part of me thinks you know we might
be better off if they'd have put hunter
biden
in the white house elise would have some
fun along the way
actually that's true um he's probably
smarter than his father but look
listening to you um it's it's really sad
that this has happened and i think that
the reason that biden voters
particularly in independence are so
disappointed and disillusioned with the
president is because his big promise
as you just said was to unify the
country a divided country already but
all he's done is exacerbate those
divisions he has done it uh not
inadvertently but spitefully
deliberately
pitching american against american uh
basically slandering 75 million trump
voters as white supremacists and
domestic terrorists he's sicked his doj
onto mums and dads protesting at school
board meetings against
leftist brainwashing of their children
he he's demonized
the unvaccinated for some bizarre reason
he thinks that they are synonymous with
trump voters when i mean the
demographics are quite different
he just seems to be a person perhaps in
his old age who harbors resentments
against people who disagree with him and
who perhaps don't like him and as the
polls sink deeper and deeper his anger
and his resentment just becomes palpable
i mean every single public pronouncement
he makes now he looks angry he's
shouting um he's punitive and it's quite
terrifying
it's such a good point that's right that
that sort of emotional aspect is really
adds to the kind of anxiety people feel
and you know the thing that it just all
makes me think is it you know in the end
leadership it's about the person you
know and
and
like i said at the beginning of of my
remarks
you know
he's just he just doesn't he's he's
talentless that's the f he's just a
machine politician if you think about
other president whether we agree or
disagree with their policies right you
look at someone like bill clinton
clearly an incredibly skillful political
operator you know he knew how to kind of
appeal to the center and so on um
lots of other faults but you know there
was something about him you could see
why he was there same with president
obama you know he had brilliant made
brilliant speeches you know you've got
you can't fault him as a family man you
know there are things about
other people who've got to this position
where you can see yeah i get it with
biden there's just nothing
absolutely right i mean every other
president really has been
exceptional in some way and joe biden is
not and never has been and we can slate
that to the media it's their fault for
not doing the due diligence on one of
the two candidates for office uh
you know they were so determined to get
rid of donald trump and they thought
that all the other democratic candidates
the younger ones the more talented ones
were just too far left that they weren't
palatable for what is really an
electorate that's that's moderate you
know most americans are centrists and uh
so they put forward joe biden but it
wasn't the real joe biden it was the
myth of joe biden as this sort of benign
uncle this moderate politician who's
tough on crime and a pretty centrist guy
who wouldn't rock the boat who would be
empathetic to people
coming out of a pandemic who had
suffered great tragedy himself
none of these things have panned out in
fact he's a nasty person
he's cognitively failing and he's also
incompetent
and i mean that's obvious yes through
his entire career and underneath it all
is this corruption uh you know it's what
i wrote about in laptop
it means that his influence peddling all
his career and and internationally when
he was vice president is now impacting
on his presidency because he's he's
compromised in the eyes of china and
russia america's greatest adversaries
exactly and actually you know you you
nailed it right there because the
your you know the story you pursued
relentlessly and brilliantly laid out in
your book
is the best example of how he was not
vetted properly and that's why the whole
thing was so outrageous and look what
we're stuck with miranda thank you so
much great to see you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else